how has has sort of a revitalized faith
influenced your 12 like that like to do
I've written three scripts that are paid
based one Mossad and adaptation Olympic
cross pair which essentially tell the
story of what happened to me and of
course my faith right is sort of my
narrative way it's a lot of you and then
then I wrote the piece of Our Lady of
Guadalupe it was revered worldwide and
then and I think it's really moving an
interesting script and then I wrote this
great Mel Gibson the Maccabees play but
none of the three soul no man and none
of the three scripts old and I think
it's very difficult to sell them the I'd
certainly like to do more because it's
very close to my heart but what I was
discouraged in terms of trying to I'm
trying to trying to get these made I
think about a piece saying that Mark
Burnett at Roman tell me who did you
know the the the the Son of God in the
Bible are looking for four other pieces
of a faith-based nature and I'll try to
talk to them and see if they understand
that's very difficult why did he that is
because if you see a country that is so
into their faith and church and God and
it seems like it would be a huge market
is it fear of Hollywood is it commercial
fear what do you think why is it so I
think the evidence is commercially that
faith-based groups can make a lot I mean
if you look at God isn't dead you know
for example recently a very small
picture and I wound up making 80 million
bucks
I didn't and incidentally it's good it's
not badly telling commercial values are
good not all of them have been but this
one is in the main 80 million bucks I
think there's an anti-christian
prejudice of element really do let's
let's go to the bottom line I really
think there is an end and they don't
wanna make them you know and it's tough
to convince them to make them and maybe
with the success of these other things
you know like goddess God it's not dead
and then in the the Bible the son of God
and no I some ways you know which which
did look for in a million dollars with
what maybe that'll change you know what
I certainly look at this and how did you
connect with Mel Gibson to start working
on the map in this project he gave to me
like the will I wrote the script about
our labor a little bit and he's sold out
got all over there's a director Ryan and
then he came to me and he said I want to
talk to you I don't want it to earlier
out a little bit um you know but I have
an idea so I did you come down here and
talk to me so idea and uh the any later
now that I thought it was an interesting
interesting story I didn't know I'm not
nineteen of Catholics I'm not the most
scholarly person about to buy because
Catholics have this thing where they
don't they were not really that much in
the scripture so I did but knowing that
to me and
and he said reader than I did and we got
together again and I and I said I think
this is an absolutely wonderful
supporting and great human drama and
it's a great choice in terms of heroism
and all of that you know it would be
people putting their lives on the line I
think could you just explain a little
bit about what Maccabees the Maccabees
were family mana ties MacCabe and his
son Judah and his brothers who during
the in around 350 before Christ during a
Greek occupation rose up and rose the
people in Judea that to allow them their
paint and their religion to be destroyed
by the Greeks and indeed the and they
literally staged a freedom fight that's
unparalleled in the history of the world
and they they rallied people around them
and and all of that and ultimately they
were triumphant over the Greece and the
Wars dispense Isis is today in terms of
the Jews and they try out and then they
beat the Greek side of it the
essentially they did it as a family and
as a band of brothers you know this
despite so you know I thought this was a
wonderful story and and uh and for a lot
of personal reasons I want to do this
story like my greatest art and then
allowing like that my greatest pain with
this and I thought I probably and
because he came to me and said let's do
this
I can't do it myself he has the script
right in the so it's frozen in some
gourds
and I'm not sure there's a chance that
we'll never get it out
you